thank you for coming and my name is
Marie Katina and I am please join us and
I facilitate this workshop series
please join us we have plenty of plenty
of room we have some refreshments in the
back so help yourself is the as we're
talking and also we have a sign-in sheet
if you'd like to leave us with your
contact information we would dearly love
to get there to alert me to other events
as they as they occur on this workshop
series is hosted by I surf and the oral
history master's program and it's held
every Tuesday every other Tuesday I'm
sorry and about six o'clock so we have
dr. menu full of love today and I'd like
to introduce dr. full of love and I have
to say dr. Phillip has been so generous
with her time with oral history master's
program that illness and as
finish my introduction if any of the
students would like to to add something
to the introduction please feel free dr.
Mindy full love is a research
psychiatrist at New York State
Psychiatric Institute and a professor of
clinical psychiatry and public health at
Columbia University she was educated at
Bryn Mawr and Columbia and she is a
board-certified psychiatrist having
received her training at the New York
Hospital Westchester division and
Montefiore hospital she's conducted
research on AIDS and epidemics of poor
communities and with special interest in
the relationship between the collapse of
communities and decline in health from
her research she has published book
shock no tearing of city neighborhoods
hurts America and what we can do about
that and we'll be hearing more about
that this evening and the house of
Joshua meditations on family in place
she is a co-author of Roderick walk
Roderick Wallace's collective
consciousness as its discontents
institutional district distributed
cognition racial policy in public health
in the United States she's published as
numerous articles and book chapters of
my monographs and it received many many
awards including best actors list and
two honorary doctorates her work in aids
is featured in Jacob Levinson's the
secret I could academic the story of
aids in black America and she is
currently finishing a new book elephants
of urban restoration preparing America's
cities after blight blight Madison
I was sharing with them some deep
secrets really cool a bit stay between
us so it's a pleasure to be here today
what I wanted to talk about was the
problem of learning of knowing we're
going to the field took to learn and my
work is as a qualitative researcher so
the idea of qualitative research is that
is the philosophy is that at a certain
point there is going to be some
inductive leap and you're going to
understand that philosophers say that
the difference between deduction and
induction is that in deduction the
answer is in the data so the most famous
syllogism in deductive reasoning the
basic one is Socrates is a man all men
are mortal therefore Socrates is mortal
so all the things that you need to get
to the answer are given to you was the
induction at a certain point there's a
leap and the answer is not in my path to
medical school in the organic chemistry
textbook there was footnote
to like kind of funny footnote but what
was the story about how the guy who
understood that the six carbons that are
the basis of life were organized in a
ring and that was that he went to sleep
in a dream and in the dream a snake
grabbed his tail in his mouth and so
that circle was he woke up and he was
like Eureka I found it so you knew there
were six carbons but how are they were
organized he didn't know so the answer
was not in the dating add up like fine
the answer popped into his head so this
is a an interesting experience and as a
qualitative researcher I've had this
experience on the number of occasions
where my head went pop and so I just
wanted to think about how do we how do
we understand that and you know sort of
this is more just my musings on the
subject of the so the thing that I
wanted to just talk about this sort of a
seeing what's in front of us just a very
short number of slides here that
I got invited to Pittsburgh to do a
project which had to do with the I was
actually a visiting fellow at the
Graduate School of Public Health at the
University of Pittsburgh and the project
was initiated by community leaders who
understood that Hope 6 was coming to its
first Hope six is a federal project
which authorized the demolition of
housing projects saying that were
considered to be distressed communities
so the the leaders in Pittsburgh had
lived through urban renewal and they
were suspicious of what this whole thing
is gonna be about so they invited me to
come and hang out and and we all got
involved in talking this through so when
I got to Pittsburgh this what I saw so
in the neighborhood where all our
meetings this is the neighborhood where
all our meetings were held not exactly
on that street but it's a typical shop
my previous research had looked a great
deal at a program called Plan tree and
plant Redux was important because I
started my research career looking at
aids in black and Hispanic communities
in the United States a major paper by
rod Wallace whose book collective
consciousness I'm co-author of physicist
who does work in human ecology did some
major work looking at the AIDS epidemic
and you know in the United States
particularly now it's spread in New York
City and his analysis demonstrated that
the implementation of the policy of
planned shrinkage in New York City in
the 1970s spread AIDS so plant shrinkage
was a program that closed fire stations
preferentially in poor and minority
neighborhoods so South Bronx are along
the bed style these neighborhoods the
fire stations were closed so that they
would burn down and the people would be
dispersed out of those neighborhoods and
the areas would be cleared so they
planned to shrink the city by destroying
some neighborhoods they ever do that in
France so I mean this policy is so
strange loving that most people don't
believe it and and so people that the
urban myth is that beat and as soon as I
say that to people they're like I know I
know yes the landlord's committed arson
and you know what's interesting about
that is and it actually relates to what
I'm talking about tonight is that having
just explained that the city government
closed fire stations so that things
would burn down people say oh yes the
landlord's committed arson which is the
prevailing folk interpretation of what
happened what happens when you close
fire stations is that it takes longer to
get to a fire fires move through
buildings exponentially so any short
delay increases the damage that will
occur in a building and so it's opposed
to a fire being contained in an
apartment and I go through several
floors or through a whole building
before the fire trucks get there so
closing fire stations is disastrous for
the protection of the
infrastructure and poor neighborhoods
have the worst code enforcement the most
overcrowding the oldest housing stock
therefore the most vulnerable housing
stock so delay in getting to fires is
very bad there's a secondary process
that was originally described by Java
four named Michael dear working in
Philadelphia which is what's called
contagious housing destruction and that
he discovered that if you destroy one
building the building's adjacent to it
become very vulnerable and so that
destroying a building on one block puts
all the buildings around it at risk and
then as one that that block burns down
the buildings around that block get to
be a person so not only does closing a
fire station increase the risk of that
building if a building burns the
buildings around it will go so what New
York City neighborhoods look like in mid
90s was that so this is a combination of
various kinds of disinvestment so plan
shrinkage was a particular policy where
they literally said let's shrink the
city let's close the fire stations to
move towards that goal we'll clear some
neighborhoods in Corbin Rd neighborhoods
uh
but not everybody said that so it's
glistening they just did it they just
took everything out I was working in
Bayview Hunters Point in San Francisco
when the last institutional thing which
was a branch of Wells Fargo Bank closed
so there was no place to get a sandwich
there was no place to
some ways to do anything there's a
supermarket is there was no
institutional supports for urban life
without getting in a car going someplace
outside I couldn't walk to him so when I
got to Pittsburgh and I was in the hill
I saw contagious housing destruction
disinvestment in contagious housing
construction that's how I read that
landscape and you you would not be if
you see that landscape and you read it
as disinvestment in the American context
you will always be right but I had a
disturbing experience which was that
these people in Pittsburgh kept talking
about urban renewal and I really I knew
about urban renewal but I was talking
about disinvestment and they were
talking about urban renewal and we were
it wasn't in my mind it was a class so
as I remember this I kind of experience
it like this buzzing me gonna be but
like a fly or a mosquito asleep at night
and the mosquitos trying to get you and
it's that really loud scary guy like and
you're like trying to kill it before it
bites you whatever thanks grace it kind
of like that
so
one day I was reading a magazine called
double taken which was a artsy magazine
short-lived beautiful artsy magazine and
they had a story about an
african-american photographer from
Memphis called
earnest withers who had taken tens of
thousands of photographs of black life
in Memphis and and he's very famous
because Martin Luther King was killed in
Memphis and he was taking pictures of
the garbage strike and all that was
going on about that time so so the
beautiful pictures of Martin Luther King
leading the March the day before a
couple days before his death or taken by
Ernest withers he is also famous because
it turns out he was an FBI Informer so I
guess that makes him infamous but back
to my sister in double-take there was
this picture I'm exaggerating this
picture was not in double tape this
picture was on the internet so I
couldn't find double tape today so but
it's alright just you know what do you
see in this photograph
would you hate it very much if I made
you go back
so this we go forward
and this are two different eras and they
can be read with if you know the history
of african-american neighborhoods in the
United States with great assurance as
being different representing different
social states the so what is important
everything that's a that's everything
that's important about the southern
state can be it should not be inferred
from this photograph but if you've read
descriptions of what was going on or if
you like me are old and lived back then
you know what was going on and that is
that she is smiling she was beautifully
groomed and dressed
it's a well-tended store a little lunch
counter and it was there to serve an
african-american community that had
enough money to go to a nice lunch
counter with a beautifully dressed and
well cocked witches so all of these are
signs of the state of health of that
community paper that I think is an
instant classic by a woman named Eva
Maria Simms which I'll be talking about
as we go along
anyway she makes the Sheep pointed this
out as what I've come to call Sims 1
sims 1 is the period from 1930 to 1960
when things look like that so but to get
back to me I looked at that photograph
and had a moment of incredible
revelation in Pittsburgh
there's photographer named Charles
teenie Harris who has the nickname of
one shot Charlie hasn't I mean a second
nickname is one child he was an
african-american photographer who worked
for the Pittsburgh courier
and he took photographs between 1940 and
1970 and during that period of time with
his Speed Graphic
so very large format camera negative
this paper God took eighty thousand
photographs so that's not like me with
my digital camera taking eighty thousand
a day this is like this is a lot of work
and he was called one shot because he
would arrive and take one shot his
photographs are proudly displayed all
over the hill and
therefore the photographs of life in the
hill were part of my experience of going
to visit people's homes and so I had
seen this photograph but it was taken in
Pittsburgh and in the way that that my
brain works in such moments you know you
know how safecrackers get to that moment
where they you know all the tumbler is
whatever the tumblers it is they do they
did and the door opens so I have this
feeling of the tumblers tumbling like
they tumble and the dirt that's how it
feels to me tumbles and the door opens
and what I realized in that moment was
that african-american communities that
looked like that in the nineteen fifties
had
existed all across the United States
that African American people are
organized in this archipelago was
because we've been confined to ghettos
but the ghettos are interconnected so
it's that in the nation within the
nation is not people clumped together
but in this complex aren't you fella go
and that so that what you saw in Memphis
you saw in Pittsburgh anyway so
Pittsburgh you saw I grew up and you saw
it in any black community where there
were photographs you would see that some
version of that program that woman
upstanding prosperous well-dressed in an
ice storm serving her community with a
smile and that a huge number of those
communities had lived through urban
renewal between 1949 and 1973 when 2500
projects were carried out in 1002 thirds
of the million people who were displaced
we're after the American and so that at
the moment when the safe opened what I
realized with in a way that stunned me
was what it meant
to have that kind of carpet bombing of
the african-american people I've never
had anybody understand what I was trying
to say it know that I'm using now
terribly articulate about this I've
never had anybody understand it better
than a group of black Vietnam veterans
that I had honored to address in
Washington DC and they all say yes we
did that in Vietnam we carpet bombed the
villages where we thought they were
vehicle many many many villages were
taken out to destroy the strength of
Vietnamese school so this whole process
this urban renewal is not just one
neighborhood or one suit and I think I
think I'm not alone in knowing there's
urban renewal in New York right Nora
it's a huge amount of her people
thinking of it is something that
happened to my city but not really
realizing the extent to which it was
happening to let's just say 1600
african-american neighborhoods across
the United States so what does that do
to a key
come you have the next time so
so teeny hours left these 80,000
negatives which are now in the Carnegie
Library sorry in the Carnegie Museum in
Pittsburgh and at this moment as we
speak there's a massive exhibit of a
thousand of his photographs displayed in
chronological order which I got to see
on Saturday but I hadn't seen many of
his photographs before and they've had a
number of smaller exhibits and they've
been doing very extensive work to get
the help of the people of Pittsburgh to
identify the photographs they weren't
well catalogued so they've been trying
to catalog them with the help of local
people who were there and so they had
books of the photographs that you could
look through and I also worked with them
to get there quite a number of
photographs by teeny hairs that are in
my book roots op so I spent quite a bit
of time with the kinds of documents that
were available
but the exhibit is fabulous it's in
three huge rooms so if you can see all
the way at the end there's a slide so
when you first come in as a large room
with benches for the really big really
big benches and there are themes and
there are like eight things and each
theme has a slideshow so what we see in
front of us is the theme the rise and
fall of the Prophet River and so all of
the photographs related to the rise and
fall of the cross or grill which was the
preeminent jazz spot in the hill aren't
playing on that there's another one
called gatherings and so all the falls
are photographs relations that are
playing so it's huge now remember this
is a speed graphic so that the amount of
information that's on the negative is
phenomenal so a wall-sized projection is
so exquisite it's there because you can
get to see everything that's there and I
mean you could just spend days just in
that room in the next room it's the same
photographs are displayed on a smaller
version on the wall by here so it starts
I believe in 1940 and then there are
selected photographs from each year and
there's an occasional commentary so for
example we'll say African Americans were
50% of this I'm making this up but 50%
of the still workers in this year
so so it helps you to track what's
happening in the embedding context of
this community and what's evident and in
a way that we have never seen before and
if you are history and you're gonna do
any work on the african-american
community you have to go see this these
photographs you have to work in this
archive but we have never seen before is
anybody who has documented as seriously
the complexity and the just plain fun of
the african-american community as it
existed in that period simply assumes
one period so there's everything you can
imagine
so there's guys coming back from the
deer hunt with venison for the
neighborhood there's a guy who pushes
his piano along to play on the streets
there's processors
there's boxers there's people in the bar
there's musicians there's famous people
on another note the the dense complex
variety of life the things that people
were interested in doing
it's almost without limit and what's
fascinating about teenie Harris I think
is that he took pictures of everything
how many people take pictures of
everything
I think people fall into themes if you
had a look at my photo archive I mean
you don't really want to ever do that in
your life but it would all be like
boring buildings you know really narrow
interest but eating hours to pictures of
and so imagine 80,000 photographs so
memories called one shot so it's in
theory 80,000 unduplicated photographs
which means that it's 80,000 shop how do
you take 80,000 pictures in a
neighborhood and not bore people well
the answer is it was a really
interesting we also know that this was
an interesting neighborhood because it's
the inspiration for August Wilson's
cycle of the place this extraordinary
place so
we get to 1960 and something happens and
that something is really renewable
and the way they show every renewal is
both through the rise and fall of the
Prophet grill which is depicted in a
series of photographs of the demolition
of the building until the area is bare
and also the rise of the Civic Arena
Civic Arena is the urban renewal cleared
land that was blighted blight was a
cancer that was going to destroy the
city so this amazing interesting complex
neighborhood worthy of a Pulitzer Prize
winning plays and 80,000 I mean this guy
is going to be the most important
african-american stars of the Commun
century no doubt about it
so worthy of depiction in those ways
this neighborhood goes light and the
cancer in the city and it was cleared
with bulldozers so that Civic Arena
could be built had the distinction of
having a retractable roof and it had a
retractable roof because the department
store magnate Edgar Kaufmann who for
whom Frank Lloyd Wright built falling
water like to hear civic Light Opera in
the out of doors so um
and this turned out that they were
highwayman the protectable move didn't
work though it was rarely opened but you
know what in the Museum of a friend baby
he's telling me this story about all the
different concerts he heard at the Civic
Arena he said most of them could been
anywhere but except for one and he
started telling you about this this
concert and it was very smoky because
everybody in there was stoned and so
they opened the retractable roof to
clear all the smoke and it started to
pour so then they had to close the
protective anyway that that's a unique
thing so the Civic Arena is erected and
so there are two things one is a map of
the of the streets and a circle of where
the Civic Arena goes and then a long
series of photographs of the erection of
the Civic Arena where this neighborhood
used to be
there's a third room where there's a
slideshow going on with voiceovers this
is after the soup after lacrosse a grill
has been cleared so this is the last
days of the Lord Hill as the African
American historic african-american
so this is this is what people were
we're talking about I just want to make
a small point which is that this we have
his lawyer
so the Crocker grill was like widely
active this is why we have been so
Crawford Brown was about there so sooner
Green is sitting when people were
talking about urban renewal they're
talking about this but what I was
visiting I was visiting in this
territory a little further up than
what's called the middle so this is
where you have the development of
contagious housing destruction and so
the life of the neighborhood continued
in a different place so this was no
longer part of the African American it
had been taken for a white use pretty
much white
and so african-american people that I
was working with did not go there and I
was hanging out with it so I went where
they went so I never went there so what
they were talking about was something I
did not see and it took a long time
before the what I was hearing about and
what I was seeing the complexity of this
terrain and its history was evidence me
so so the point at which I'm seeing
Ernest withers photographs somehow helps
me overcome the limitations of my my own
lived experience and enter fully into
what people are trying to get me
understand
but honey - so even Maria since had an
epiphany herself she doesn't describe
the numbers tumblers rolling on the
safer but what she says in a paper
that's in humanistic psychology in 2008
see the teenie Harris exhibit read even
reassemble paper
she says that phenomenologist and they
think they like to know how people
experience things so she went to the
Hill District to learn how people play
this children and you know so that means
really the questions that are on their
mind or you know did you build a hut in
the woods and how many other kids were
in your neighborhood and what games a
phenomenologist like this to describe
those things and very exquisite terms
when she came back with her data and she
sat down and analyzed it she was
startled to find that the data said
something quite different from what she
expected and that was that the people
who had grown up in different years so
she interview people between 1930 in
2004 had remarkably different
experiences so growing up between 1930
and 1960 the error before the renewal
was an error of this dense positive
productive interesting complicated
thriving neighborhood Jane Jacobs talks
a lot about cities Jean Jacobson death
and life of great American cities talks
a lot about the fact that cities that
work are good places for people who have
plans of their own
and if you ever wanted to see you know
so what does that mean people have plans
of their own but these photos of teeny
arrows which are actually all in the
Internet
not all but a huge selection of Internet
you know like let's go deer hunting and
bring the deer back and feed the hungry
this is not my plan but there are guys
and they had a truck that was the annual
feed the deer here for food something
they had a title for this day um the a
lot of people have different a lot of
different plans all there so
if you were growing up in that first era
you grew up in a dense dense dense set
of relationships that you were looked
after by all of the adults and you
existed in a posse of all the kids
these people were intensely socialized
and they were socialized to think about
community they're socialized to be
responsible for their entire food
they were socialized to be poverty
solvers there was socialized to be
positive citizens they're supposed
socialized to be cleaned up sent that
doesn't mean there weren't some
criminals but wha but it was not out of
control it was not uncontainable so an
teenie Harris has pictures of the
numbers runners of the murders this and
that just took pictures of everything
so 1960 with urban renewal also at that
time Pittsburgh is beginning to D
industrialize so african-americans are
losing their jobs and with steel mills
we go into a new era Sims 2 which
extends to 1984 since 2 is a period of
fraying of the networks it's the whole
loss of the lower Hill people are moving
into the middle Hill the middle Hill is
starting to burn down the middle of that
period there are the riots in response
to the riots Pittsburgh cuts many of the
existing roads in and out of the Hill
District two isolated you know kind of
contain the black people and so people
no longer have the sense that there's
that we're all in it together a
different solid different trajectory
between 1984 and 2004 that's when she
dates it might be 1980 to 2004 is when
she dates soon as three and that's
characterized by what one of the people
she interviews tells her is his sense of
unexpected see which is remarkable she
points out a remarkable meal
when I when I go out of my door he says
I was gonna happen I was like look to
the left look to the right see what's
going on hope you don't get shot but you
don't know that you can get safely from
your house to wherever so the kind of
wandering around exploring woods beings
or the people we're in this together I
can trust you because you're in the hill
with me
whoever you are if you're the numbers
runner you're a criminal you're still
gonna take care of me coz on the little
kid that's gone and now it's just a
sense of you
so it seems three yes really a period
when it's supposed to all the adults
raising all the children you're down to
a single mother raising kids without
much help from neighbors or friends or
family so that both the strong ties and
weak ties have been shattered and people
are living in very isolated very
frightened
excellent
so just so this assumes three
that's what I'm - we're seeing and as we
could put these stories together as we
understand the rule and we understand we
understand this long process we realize
I realized this was not simply
contagious housing destruction it is
contagious housing destruction it's not
simply contagious housing choice and
ultimately we're really forced to remain
what we're seeing and because there's a
series of displacements and upheavals
and destructions that are going on and
we come to call that serial displacement
so
so I said so as I said I was in
Pittsburgh this past weekend and I was
touring around with an architect who's
worked a lot in Braddock so Braddock is
another devastated
little was a Steel City it still
important steel mill they're 35,000
people almost everybody depended on the
steel metal still most close massive
deindustrialization and the town
collapsed there they're now about 2,000
people that live in red Braddock is
devastated so so the architects who are
working their first major investment on
Main Street in Braddock putting up a
building and part of the building is
gonna be parking so it's going to
present a blank wall to the street so
for architects and people who are trying
to do urban restoration this is an
important thing but here's a here's a
Main Street where the buildings are
mostly gone a lot of vacant lots what
buildings there are mostly closed so
there's not much there to give the
street that 3 dimensional existence that
makes it look like a street chain Jacobs
has the expression that buildings are
the natural proprietors of the street
and as the owners of the street they're
not supposed to turn their back on the
street so these architects are there
they're convinced of this they're not
going to
so that means that this part where
there's going to be parking there's
going to be a blank wall to the street
you have to have something to deal with
that you have to you have to own the
building this is the first new
construction in 20 years it has to own
the street how do you do that when you
have a blank wall so they come up with
the idea of an art project and they call
in a citizen's Commission to say so what
should the art be and what's remarkable
is that the citizens who are on this Art
Commission get together and basically
for 45 minutes they're telling stories
sharing stories with each other about
growing up in Braddock living at
Braddock and loving Freddie
and so then there's a second meeting and
they tell my story then there's a third
meeting and the architect is scratching
his head and saying it's not getting any
more I'm gonna get this project that who
are we gonna do for the card and then he
is a light bulb goes off and he realizes
that the stories are the project there
one has to be set on Main Street is that
this is a beloved place and so there are
a series of panels by this artist Robert
cultures that were made by a
collaboration among the developer the
architect and people of Brett and the
artist and in this one this one is
called parades so in Braddock said we
had great parades and credit I remember
the time we we rode on the latter truck
we all sat right on the ladders and she
candy to everyone there were so many
people on the sidewalks I miss the good
tours what they talked about was the
parade you see the t-shirt Braddock
woods was that main streets two miles
long and parades with one four five
hours
ya know what their hearkening back to is
Braddock one that's the ellipse Braddock
one
but they wanted they want you to know
just the way that people in the Hill
District put up teeny Harris's photos so
where we're coming from we love this
place because of that that's what we
lived it's that's the legacy of the
place and so these Bart pebbles are
proudly displayed on the sides of this
building and in front of every panel
there's a bench
no in the bench of spacing the panel so
you could sit on the bench I had a
student so back in the 90s there were a
lot of murders boy who study memorial
walls all over New York City and one of
the interesting things about memorial
walls that she found was that there were
several kinds of ways people went to the
space of the memorial one was that
people would sit and be the guardians of
the space but second was that people
would just pass through if they were
just going to the store they weren't
there to deal with you more and the
third was that people came to grieve or
to connect if you've ever visited the
Vietnam Veterans Memorial law or some
pictures of it you'll notice it's the
same structure that that there are you
can be you can just walk through you can
stand in via guardian or you can touch
it you can leave presence you
you can find your lost loved ones there
so in organizing this they created
morning space for four people - so what
is putting public memorials at this
point what are they doing for us
and why did the architects provide that
for the people of Drabek as this first
new construction of Braddock Avenue
owning the street the proprietors of the
street it's both the loss and the
assertion that we clean the only
credible memorial to somebody we make it
clear we do not want to forget we will
remember this we will take it into our
DNA of the future and so these pictures
do that so my goal here was just to
describe this this sub cognitive process
of induction which is a mystery to us
it's a black box that the light goes off
and we don't know why do I actually told
you four stories the guy who discovered
the carbon ring and how I came to
recognize that root shock was a national
process and how even Maria Simms learns
about these three errors and Dan
Rothschild realized that the stories
were the project for the art so I think
induction is very common in our
experience of trying to move through the
world as creative people it's curious
and it's not programmed it's not
something we can say we have got all the
data let me sit down let me do my
analysis and then I'll know it has not
been my experience that you know the
answer
so I was sharing with the oral history
students that during this time in
Pittsburgh
I was driving down driving down Main
Street I'm driving down make sure the
damn road stops partner can join up and
I'm looking at all the vacant lots on
Brett Academy and he's telling me about
all the buildings that it good so it
smell it what I'm seeing is what poor
hearing is not what I'm saying
and I remembered I was doing this
lecture on like listening carefully
something we have to listen carefully
actually said that's now I'm listening
carefully and I'm like this is a
disconnect because this place is nothing
but I mean it's just short of Rumble
like it I mean it's not free and he's
talking about this very positive and I'm
like Dee do you think about this week at
once and he said No
and the tumblers rolled and the door
opened and I and I've got something I've
been trying to get for a long time which
is you may have read articles people are
saying oh we have to do plenty in
kitchen Youngstown we have to plant
refuge in Detroit and I'm always saying
I don't know if you want to do that
because that's how we got the worldwide
AIDS epidemic it may be able to chill
that out that's a bad idea
but but then the people say well what do
you do and there are a lot of vacant
lots in those cities what you do so what
I got in that moment suddenly on
Braddock Avenue was the people who have
the clearest vision are not looking at
the bigots but that's what they're
looking at they're looking at above
so love conquers all is the answer for
the American city
and then our job as people who for me as
a psychiatrist and as clinician with me
fuz new spaces is how do we how do we
lift that up how do we tell those
stories how do we share them having me
affirm the dignity and the contributions
of people who have been so badly abused
by our society that their cities were
and so that is what I want to show her
to me well by the way it was a very
intense experience it's like I can't
even begin to describe
I tried and spoke to them very intense
and this great psychedelic I lost my
yesterday I'm still tripping a little
bit trying to be cool so induction can
be it's quite a it's quite a thing when
it happens in your head how it happens
so as I like to say in short to my
students when I'm teaching qualitative
research the answer is not in the data
which doesn't mean you don't have to
know your data but the answer is just
gonna come through you as if you are a
child and the st. Francis prayer Lord
make me a channel of my piece
Lord make me a channel of thy love so I
can see
thank you for your attention there now
I've asked some people to co-presented
me and we collected some stories in our
work together so we have to start each
other's if it will take over at this
point and then we'll open it up for just
just just to show that this is happening
to all of us the story is that when one